( intro music )
About a week
into our expedition
a rebel group from the
Islamic Movement of Uzbekistan
moved through the valley
and they saw us 1,000 feet
up on this big wall
and they saw this as
this opportunity.
And so, we awoke one morning
to bullets flying
around our portaledges.
The message was quite clear.
We had to come down
or we would get shot.
So, we spent a couple hours
rappelling to the ground.
And when we got to the
ground, we were greeted with
these very scary-looking
guys, with big guns
and army fatigues and
large beards and...
We were taken hostage.
And, few hours after we were
actually taken as hostages
the Kyrgyz Military
moved into the valley
and this incredible battle
erupted all around us.
We watched in horror as
a Kyrgyz shoul-- soldier was
shot point blank in the head.
And we were forced to lie on
his body for like four hours
as this crazy battle
raged around us.
Heavy machine gun fire, mortars
were shot over our heads.
And then for the next
six days we hid.
During the day we would bury
ourselves in holes in the ground
cover ourselves up with brush
and lay completely still.
At night we would sneak from
one location to the next.
On the sixth night of captivity
something clicked inside of me
like, this real
survival instinct kicked in.
I suddenly felt as though
I'd be able to sprint uphill
without my heart rate
even rising.
So, a plan was hatched
for the head captor
to try and like head back to our
basecamp and get some food.
And then we were told to climb
up this steep mountainside
with our one remaining captor.
And so we started climbing
we were climbers, very
comfortable on this terrain
our captor was not comfortable.
And I started to think if we
didn't get out of here soon
like, we might not last
very much longer.
And so,
when we were probably
a couple thousand feet
up this mountainside
in a super exposed section
of the climb...
I decided that I had to take
matters into my own hands.
So, I scrambled up behind
this one remaining captor
and I grabbed the gun strap
for the gun that was
strapped over his shoulder
and I yanked backwards
on it as hard as I could
and I watched him fall 50 feet,
hit a sloping ramp and then
off into the blackness.